l'attaque a surpris des habitants venus
faire leurs courses dans ce supermarché
cet enfant est légèrement blessé
le missile n'est pas entré dans le
magasin lui-même il a traversé le toit
et c'était écrasé sur l'asphalte du
parking c'est là que les éclats se sont
envolés du toit la fumée à causé de la
panique tout le monde était tabac sur
dix j'ai vu deux morts et je ne me
souviens de rien d'autre
un missile est également tombé tout près
de cette gare
les secours sont arrivés rapidement
le trafic a pu reprendre deux heures
plus tard
l'armée ukrainienne accuse la Russie
d'avoir délibérément ciblé des zones
résidentielles
n'étaient en aucun cas justifiées
militairement
elle visait uniquement des civils
c'est bombardements interviennent alors
que les autorités ont annoncé un
couvre-feu qui doit débuter ce vendredi
soir jusqu'à lundi matin pendant 58
heures il sera interdit de se déplacer
et de se trouver dans la rue tout accès
à la ville sera coupée c'est
restrictions visent à laisser l'armée
faire son travail justifie les autorités
alors que les forces ukrainiennes disent
se préparer à une vaste contre-offensive
pour reprendre les zones sous contrôle
russe la ville de Kerson occupée pendant
plusieurs mois en 2022 par les troupes
de Moscou avaient été libérés en
novembre après une première
contre-offensive réussie de Kiev depuis
la ville subit des bombardements
réguliers l'armée russe ne se situant
que de l'autre côté du fleuve de nièpres
qui fait office de ligne de front
naturelle